[Musique]
la constitution de 1958 elle a été faite
sur mesure par et pour le général de
gaulle le président de la république
fera dorénavant élu au suffrage
universel
comment ça va marcher ce nouveau monde
commence à marcher ce nouveau régime où
exactement le lieu du pouvoir
depuis 1958 elle a surmonté toutes les
crises nationales internationales
alternance politique crise économique
crise sociale crise politique
faut des règles des règles claires et
qui permettent de savoir qui dirige et
qui fait la loi
si la constitution de la vème république
pose des questions c'est parce qu'elle a
été conçue par le général de gaulle et
pour le général de gaulle
[Musique]
c'est dans la légalité que moi même et
mon gouvernement avant d'assumer
[Applaudissements]
as tu es le mandat exceptionnel
établir un projet de constitution
nouvelle du 4 septembre 1958 le général
de gaulle présente aux français la
constitution de la vème république
c'est la onzième de notre histoire
politique depuis la révolution française
une constitution c'est la charte
fondamentale d'un pays c'est l'ensemble
des règles qui gouvernent les
institutions politiques d'un pays et qui
fixe les relations entre les citoyennes
et les citoyens et l'état on peut
vraiment dire que la constitution ce une
spécialité française et britannique
n'ont pas de constitution leur système
politique fonctionne sur la tradition
les rituels quelques textes fondateurs
et qu'en france nous avons une bonne
quinzaine de constitution de charte
constitutionnelle ou de loi
constitutionnelle qui ont défini nous
nos différents systèmes politiques les
français ont besoin de constitution si
la constitution de 1958 est né le 4
septembre
elle est surtout l'aboutissement d'un
long processus historique
il faut remonter très loin dans notre
histoire en réalité à ce qu'on appelle
la tradition bonapartiste
il ya tout un courant de la vie
politique française qui trouvent qu'il
faut un pouvoir exécutif fort un homme
fort à la tête de l'état qui s'appuie
directement sur le peuple par le biais
de l'élection ou du référendum qu'on
appelait plébiscite à l'époque des
expériences du premier et du second
empire ont profondément marqué la
société française la majorité des
républicains rejettent le système
impérial qu'ils assimilent à une
dictature mais certains réclamant
renforcement du pouvoir exécutif au nom
du redressement national
c'est le cas notamment de paul déroulède
le président de la ligue des patriotes
qui réclame dans les années 1900 une
république plébiscite heures il annonce
déjà le système présidentiel de la vème
république et aussi tout un courant qui
finalement sous la troisième république
a pris la mesure des insuffisances de ce
régime et qui veut le réformer et ce
mouvement là en réalité dont
intellectuelle des responsables
politiques léon blum tardieu me laurent
barthélémy capitan point c'est que
quelques et merci aux responsables
politiques ont mis en place tout ce
qu'il y aura de toute façon dans la
console 1958 le socialiste léon blum par
exemple publie des lettres sur la
réforme gouvernementale dont lesquelles
il plaide pour un renforcement des
pouvoirs du président du conseil face à
la chambre des députés
alexandre millerand et andré tardieu
voudrait renforcer les pouvoirs du
président de la république et surtout
qu'ils aient le droit de dissoudre la
chambre
quant aux juristes rené capitant qui
deviendra ministre de la justice sous la
vème république
il propose déjà de donner au chef de
l'état des pouvoirs exceptionnels en cas
de crise
dès sa jeunesse le général de gaulle a
lui aussi porter un regard critique sur
le régime parlementaire un parlement qui
selon lui parle trop et n'agit pas assez
lorsqu on débouche sur la guerre de 1914
le capitaine de gaulle qui combat estime
que le régime parlementaire est tout à
fait incapable de conduire la guerre
alors on connaît une lettre qu'il a
adressée à sa mère en 1915 où il dit
tout le mal qu'il pense du régime
parlementaire
le parlement devient de plus en plus
odieux et bêtes des ministres ont
littéralement toute leur journée prise
par les séances de la chambre du sénat
où la lecture des injonctions les plus
saugrenues du premier marchand de vins
venus que la politique a changé en
députés nous serons vainqueur dès que
nous aurons balayé cette racaille
depuis le secrétariat général de la
défense nationale où il a été nommé en
1931 le général de gaulle observent de
près l'impuissance du système politique
de la troisième république
il ya d'ailleurs une anecdote fameuse où
le général de gaulle reçu par le
président du conseil léon blum revendu
du front populaire voit sa conversation
interrompue à plusieurs reprises par des
coups de fil qui viennent de la chambre
des députés et qui oblige véritablement
le président du conseil l'homme du
pouvoir exécutif
finalement à se plier aux péripéties de
la chose parlementaire et c'est là que
le général de gaulle comprend que ce
système parlementaire est un système un
puissant qui n'arrive pas à résoudre les
problèmes parce qu'il est trop long
parce que il empêche celui qui exécute
d'avoir le pouvoir nécessaire pour
imposer sa décision est la même époque
général de gaulle publie une série
d'ouvragés le fil de l'épée en 1932 vers
l'armée de métier en 1934 la france et
son armée en 1938 il y expose notamment
ses idées sur l'autorité militaire et
sur l'art de commander dans le premier
il écrit les hommes se passe points au
fond d'être dirigé non plus que de
manger boire et dormir ces animaux
politiques ont besoin d'organisation
c'est à dire d'ordre et de chef et au
fond c'est parce qu'il est un militaire
d'abord un militaire qu'il comprend la
nécessité et la force du commandement
qu'il veut transposer ce tropisme du
commandement vers le monde politique
vers la fonction présidentielle
c'est-à-dire un président de la
république qui sera le général en chef
un premier ministre qui serait chargé de
l'exécution comme chef d'état major
général
et puis des généraux dans les ministères
dont chacun aurait à gérer son corps
d'armée de fonctionnaires et les
problèmes qui sont afférents à partir de
1940 le général de gaulle joue un rôle
majeur en tant que chef de l'armée
distance il constitue en comité français
de libération nationale puis un
gouvernement provisoire de la république
française
à la libération celui qui apparaît comme
le vainqueur de la guerre il
profondément opposé au projet de
l'assemblée chargée de rédiger la
nouvelle constitution de la quatrième
république
c'est pourquoi il démissionne le 20
janvier 1946 de la présidence du
gouvernement et se monte à bayeux cinq
mois plus tard le 16 juin pour exprimer
son désaccord et exposer ses idées ou
chef de l'état
la fonction de promulguer les lois et de
prendre les décrets parce que ses
vis-à-vis de l'état tout entier que ceux
ci comme celle-là
engagerez citoyens le discours de bayeux
c'est d'abord une rupture avec ce projet
de constitution élaboré par les
assemblées parlementaires
sept la dénonciation du régime des
partis c'est l'idée qu' on n'a pas
construit un président de la république
guide de la nation arbitres de l'intérêt
national mais on inaugure heures de
chrysanthèmes comme de gaulle appellera
que le pouvoir
de l'état est dans les mains du
parlement des partis politiques des
combinaisons et donc qu'il n'y aura pas
de pouvoir gouvernemental autrement dit
ce qui est esquissée à bayeux
c'est une synthèse entre les deux
traditions politiques que connaît la
france depuis la révolution
la tradition parlementaire qui a marqué
les différentes républiques et la
tradition autoritaire efficace qui a
marqué les deux empires pour manifester
son hostilité au régime des partis le 14
avril 1947 de gaulle décide de créer son
propre mouvement politique le
rassemblement du peuple français
ce sentiment trouvent un cadre
dans lequel ils puissent s'exprimer et
qui me permettent de devenir une force
susceptible de créer une atmosphère et
d'appuyer une politique déterminée à la
surprise générale les candidats
gaulliste remporté haut la main les
élections municipales d'octobre de la
même année ses partisans se demande
alors si le général de gaulle ne
pourrait pas revenir au pouvoir mais le
rpf après un démarrage
extrêmement positif c'était souffler le
général a dit à son entourage on arrête
je n'arriverai pas à prendre le pouvoir
il va commencer ce que l'on a appelé une
traversée du désert c'est à dire qu'il
ne joue plus de rôle politique ils
n'acceptent pas ces institutions ils
n'acceptent pas ce jeu et partis
politiques est latent et en attendant il
nourrit la réflexion la quatrième
république elle est emportée dans un
tourbillon à ces sondes instabilité
ministérielle et de compromis
politiciens ont soulevé le matin on perd
écouter la radio s'était pas encore les
transistors on apprenait qu'elle rayonne
nouveau gouvernement alors c'était félix
gaillard guy mollet c'est une ronde en
plus c'était les mêmes qui revenait j'ai
été
conseiller au ministère des finances
de 57 à 58 en un an j'ai conseillé
quatre ministres de finances différents
ramadier
gars forts films l'un gaillard etc
y'avait faillite politique du régime et
faillite économique la france étant
endetté jusqu'au cou a fait un malaise
le manque d'autorité
de l'état on reconnaissait pas l'état
tel qu'il devrait être la guerre
d'indochine puis à sa suite le conflit
en algérie ont déstabilisé la quatrième
république à alger le 13 mai 1958 le
jour même où un nouveau président du
conseil pierre fine l'un doit être
investi à paris les manifestants sont
part du palais du gouvernement général
c'est un véritable coup d'état mené par
les partisans de l'algérie française et
par une partie de l'armée dans l'ombre
les hommes du général de gaulle
notamment lucien neuwirth et léon
delbecque s'activent pour tirer profit
de la situation ils suivent de très près
tous les complots qui se déroulent en
algérie avec l'idée que le jour où un de
ces complots va provoquer un coup de
force en algérie il faudra faire dériver
le système vers la paix le général de
gaulle comme le sauveur de la nation
qu'il a déjà été en 1940 les milieux
gaullistes ont
repris espoir et se sont mobilisées lé
général de gaulle sur le lendemain de
son silence le 15 mai voyant que rien ne
se produit il va publier un communiqué
où il déclare in fine et qu' il est prêt
à assumer les pouvoirs de la république
pour résoudre la question
depuis 12 ans la france aux prises avec
des problèmes trop rude pour le régime
des partis est engagée dans ce processus
désastreux naguère le pays dans ses
profondeurs m'a fait confiance pour le
conduire tout entier jusqu'à son salut
aujourd'hui devant les épreuves qui
monte de nouveau vers lui qu'ils sachent
que je me tiens prêt à assumer les
pouvoirs de la république quatre jours
plus tard le général de gaulle donne une
conférence de presse au palais dorcel
aux journalistes qui s'inquiètent de
l'éventualité d'une dictature il ans
lorsqu'il effectivement il dit où il
répond aux journalistes qu'il ne va pas
commencer une carrière de dictateur
c'est tout simplement aussi pour dire ce
n'est pas parce que je veux faire en
sorte que le président de la république
soit un véritable chef de l'état chef de
l'exécutif que pour autant je vais
renier les principes démocratiques sur
l'échiquier politique le général
stratège avant ces pièces dans sa
volonté de conquérir le pouvoir rien ne
semble l'arrêter 28 mai le général de
gaulle publie un communiqué déclarant
contre toute réalité qu'il a entamé la
constitution d'un gouvernement
régulier de la république général de
gaulle donc va profiter des
circonstances
prendre de vitesse ceux qui sont au
pouvoir à l'époque convaincre et ça
c'était très important le président de
la république de l'époque rené coty de
l'appeler au pouvoir chasser une
république se désagrège ce dernier n'a
plus le choix il va prendre l'initiative
le 29 mai de faire appel au général de
gaulle
en échange celui-ci exige dès le début
les pleins pouvoirs et une révision
constitutionnel le 1er juin 1958 comme
le veut la tradition de la quatrième
république
il doit alors se présenter devant
l'assemblée pour obtenir son investiture
il essaye au début de pas y aller il dit
même à guy mollet je suis agoraphobe
donc je peux pas y aller les guy mollet
lui-même en général si vous venez pas
devant le parlement ça sera vécu comme
un coup d'état et de gaulle fini par s'y
rendre la rive général de gros devant
l'assemblée y fait son discours il sort
les autres sont stupéfaits et ils font
leurs discours dans le vide il signifie
physiquement que c'est fini c'est un
nouveau jeu maintenant ses plus
farouches détracteurs pierre mendès
france et françois mitterrand qu'on
donne sa démarche de manière virulente
mais il est trop tard le nouveau
gouvernement est investi le 1er juin par
l'assemblée par 329 voix contre 224 le
lendemain lors d'un nouveau vote des
parlementaires donne les pleins pouvoirs
à de gaulle pour six mois afin de
résoudre la crise qui étrangle le pays
le général de gaulle a été le dernier
président du conseil d'une quatrième
république il n'a cessé de vilipender
le 3 juin l'assemblée nationale vote la
loi constitutionnelle
par cette loi de gaulle de montrer qu'il
n'est pas un apprenti dictateur et
qu'ils se plient aux règles
fondamentales de la démocratie
c'est une loi qui donne le pouvoir au
général de gaulle pendant une durée
limitée de préparer une constitution et
qui met un certain nombre de lignes
directrices que devra respecter cette
future constitution la première c'est
d'abord le respect du suffrage universel
qui est l'émanation la souveraineté
populaire deuxième condition la
séparation des pouvoirs il faut que
chacun les pouvoirs exécutif et
législatif est une autonomie troisième
condition très importante la
responsabilité gouvernementale
il devra être contrôlée par les
assemblées et ça c'est le fondement même
du régime parlementaire quatrième
élément l'indépendance du pouvoir
judiciaire et le cinquième élément plus
conjoncturelle c'est la transformation
de ce qui existe à l'époque sous la
quatrième république ce qu'on appelle
l'union française c'est à dire l'ancien
empire colonial en une communauté
francophone qui au fond sera un peu
dérivé de ce qui existait avant d'y les
premiers jours le général de gaulle mais
ses plus proches collaborateurs au
travail dont la foulée un comité
d'experts est nommé pour rédiger un
avant-projet de la constitution michel
debré son garde des sceaux les pilotes
sera le premier entretien
que mon père a avec le général de gaulle
c'est juste au moment où le général de
gaulle vient de d'obtenir la délégation
de pouvoir
premier objectif
c'est changer la conception du rôle et
de la place du président de la
république
deuxième objectif
rétablir un véritable régime
parlementaire qui ne repose pas sur la
confusion des pouvoirs
troisième objectif c'est de faire en
sorte de répartir les compétences de la
loi les compétences du règlement c'est à
dire derrière ça
permettre l'élaboration d'un pouvoir
gouvernemental autonome du goal va leur
mettre un point d'honneur à aller très
vite il connaît déjà les grandes lignes
de son projet qu'il a évoqué lors de son
discours de bayeux en 1946 l'heure est
au changement en profondeur général
c'est un militaire il a donné ses ordres
il a fixé ses objectifs il sait que mon
père ne le contestera pas dans la mesure
où ses ordres et sélective sont déjà
influencé par mon père est le gérant de
vol il il rédige pas vraiment il a des
idées très précises sur un certain
nombre d'éléments tu veux dans la
constitution mais il parle plutôt il
parle aux autres ils écoutent fait des
commentaires ya après l'équipe l'équipe
de michel debré qui est une équipe
composée de jeunes juristes plutôt du
conseil d'état qui font la partie
technique et puis il ya les ministres
d'état qui sont réunis dans ce qu'on
appelait un comité interministériel du
mollet socialiste pierre films l'un mrp
louis jacquinot indépendant et félix
houphouët boigny qui représente l
outre-mer et qui étaient autour de
tendance centriste ironie de l'histoire
tous ont eu des postes clés durant la
quatrième république
petite équipe resserrée énergique on
travaille 24 heures sur 24
le bureau de michel debré et éclairées
en permanence et avec l'autorité du
général de gaulle donc on aboutit
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'auparavant à
une constitution très homogène très
cohérente et qui va s'imposer très vite
joint 58 fin août 58 en deux mois de
temps en fait le texte est rédigé on va
à l'essentiel les conditions de
rédaction de la révision
constitutionnelle implique la vie n'en
comité consultatif
celui ci doit être composé de 39 membres
il est présidé par l'ancien président du
conseil paul reynaud ce comité
consultatif
c'est aussi l'un des objets du compromis
1958 faut bien comprendre que le général
de gaulle arrive au pouvoir mais avec
l'accord des parlementaires ils sont
dans ce comité on ne peut pas compte
tenu de la tradition française des
assemblées constituantes complètement
les écarts l'important pour la procédure
pour le décorum pour l'histoire pour les
susceptibilités mais je pense pas que ça
change grand chose il n'y a pas au sein
du comité consultatif constitutionnel
d'opposition
importante à la logique qui est dans le
texte du gouvernement
après un mois de travaux dans les salons
du palais royal les membres du comité
consultatif constitutionnel adopte le
texte moyennant quelques amendements de
forme à l'unanimité moins quatre
abstentions après le travail du général
de gaulle et du comité interministériel
qui a été décisif après le travail du
comité consultatif constitutionnel qui a
modifié qui a ratifié essentiellement ce
qui avait déjà été fait on passe au
conseil d'état parce que le conseil
d'état au fond c'est la validation
juridique de ce qui avait déjà était
travaillé auparavant c'est nécessaire
c'est indispensable mais là aussi on ne
va pas modifier fondamentalement ce qui
a été fait auparavant c'est surtout une
ratification de ce qu'elle a été conçue
par le général de gaulle michel debré
c'est devant le conseil d'état que
michel debré a c'est le seul véritable
exposé des motifs que l'on ait de la
constitution de 1958 il a parlé pendant
plus d'une heure pour présenter le
projet en expliquant ce qu'on le
gouvernement avait dans la tête il ya
une question qui va être central au
conseil d'état c'est la distinction
entre le domaine de la loi et le domaine
du règlement ses articles 34
la restriction du domaine de la loi qui
a été considéré à l'époque en 1958 comme
la révolution juridique le fait qu'on
lise aux parlementaires vous ne pouvez
plus désormais eux représentant du
peuple légiférer sur tout et n'importe
quoi donc c'est ça en réalité la
véritable fracture entre la 5e et la
quatrième république et là effectivement
les jeunes conseillers d'état et ceux
qui ont participé à la rédaction de ce
texte évidemment n'avait pas la
référence la 4ème république donc ça
quand même aidé évidemment à la
rédaction de ces discussions alors ça ça
beaucoup heurté le conseil des temps
parce que c est totalement contraire à
la tradition
républicaine et la tradition française
ou là le parlement pouvait tout faire là
on disait le parlement ne pourra pas
tout faire et donc on a discuté des
heures et des heures là dessus et ce
n'est qu'à la dernière minute qu'on a
réussi à trouver des rédactions un peu
compliqué plus long que ce que
souhaitait michel debré le gouvernement
mais ça a été difficile seulement le
problème c'est que
ce texte constitutionnel il est le
résultat de l'action du gouvernement et
on peut s'interroger sur sa légitimité à
ce moment là puisqu'au fond la seule
légitimité qui a donné le pouvoir au
général de gaulle c'est l'émeute du 13
mai et sur le plan juridique c'est un
peu douteux au niveau des valeurs c'est
quand même une menace de coup d'état et
donc il y à
volonté du général de gaulle de faire
approuver par le peuple par référendum
cette constitution à la suite du conseil
d'état le général de gaulle présente aux
français place de la république à paris
le projet de constitution que le conseil
des ministres a adopté la veille et qui
sera soumis à référendum le 28 septembre
on sort du mystère on sort du silence le
général de gaulle va enfin parler sa
première fois tu vas parler sur le sujet
le 4 septembre 1958 est une étape
décisive
c'est le jour où le général de gaulle
choisit de présenter aux français son
projet constitutionnel avantage il faut
que les français adhèrent ils ont adhéré
à la personnalité du général de gaulle à
l'héroïsme au prestige du général de
gaulle encore faut-il adhérer aux
institutions qu'ils proposent qui sont
en rupture avec ce qu'était la tradition
parlementaire de la république depuis la
révolution française
alors on organise une grande cérémonie
place de la république lieu emblématique
cette histoire républicaine le 4
septembre
1958 référence directe à la proclamation
de la troisième république le 4
septembre 1870
donc on s'inscrit véritablement dans
cette histoire républicaine et
parlementaire il existe au dessus des
querelles politiques il existe un
arbitre national
par les citoyens y ont un mandat public
le lieu il est évidemment symbolique
place de la république ça va avec bon
sur cette grande place qui honnêtement
ce jour là n'était pas très très remplis
quand on regarde les images
complètes c'est pas à l'epa plaine du
tout un bon mais les photographes et la
télévision de l'époque fonctionne bien
et donc les français ont eu
véritablement l'impression que il était
appelé j'allais dire ap vers ces
institutions de la vème république
aux abords de la place de la république
d'autres voix se font entendre des
communistes les socialistes sont
d'ailleurs dans leur quartier historique
laisse de paris c'est la gauche pierre
mendès france parce que lui il ya une
très forte légitimité il avait été du
général de gaulle à la libération il a
été président du conseil sous la
quatrième république
c'est vraiment un homme qu'on respecte
beaucoup il ya aussi françois mitterrand
qui a été 11 fois ministre sous la
quatrième république qui est une figure
de la vie politique française ces deux
hommes là sont contre mais mais
les socialistes la majorité des
socialistes derrière guy mollet sont
favorables aux institutions de la vème
république
les partis du centre et de la droite
sont favorables aux institutions de la
vème république la campagne pour le
référendum est lancée elle sera rapide
et sera totalement dominée par le
général de gaulle il parle d'une france
libérée d'une affiche on voit marianne
et des chaînes sont cassés fait une
sorte de tournée de libérateur où ils
rentrent pas dans le détail où il porte
un discours qui est un discours de
de restauration aussi de la grandeur on
va voir des hommes même de gauche les
socialistes
les hommes du centre des zones de la
droite libérale faire campagne au nom du
général de gaulle au nom des
institutions de la vème république les
français adhéraient aux idées du général
ce référendum à 200 ch 1 la question
porte sur l'adhésion aux institutions de
la vème république sur une nouvelle
constitution mais aussi sur le projet
qui est lié à cette constitution de
créer une nouvelle communauté française
sur les décombres de l'empiré colonial
et donc on dit aux ressortissants de ces
territoires ex coloniaux que s'ils
votent pour cette constitution
il adhère donc à ce que sera cette
communauté francophone mais ils ont la
possibilité aussi de voter non auquel
cas ils deviendront indépendant oui 21
millions 322 1211
en portions de huy
81,7 non 4 millions sept cent soixante
sept mille 180
en portions
18,3 pour ça le 28 septembre plus de 4
français sur 5 adhèrent à ces
institutions
un pays d'afrique la guinée a voté non
et c'est donc exclus de la communauté
française la constitution est promulguée
par le président rené coty le 4 octobre
1958 désormais il s'agit de mettre en
place les institutions pour le général
de gaulle le premier test c'est
d'organiser les législatives
elles auront lieu le 23 et le 30
novembre de la même année à cette
occasion il abandonne le scrutin
proportionnel de la quatrième république
la quatrième république qui était un
régime des partis avaient voulu
instaurer un scrutin proportionnel de
manière à ne laisser aucun des
partenaires des coalitions
gouvernementales qui était au pouvoir
pour le général de gaulle l'état
d'esprit est différent ce qui lui
importe c'est de construire une majorité
stable est importante pour que le
pouvoir exécutif puisse justement initié
sa politique et donc le scrutin qui est
choisi c'est un scrutin majoritaire un
scrutin majoritaire de circonscription
appelle ça uninominal parce qu'il
correspond justement à la volonté pour
le général de gaulle de construire une
véritable majorité présidentielle la
campagne 58 elle se fait sur d'abord des
nouveaux candidats bien grand coup de
balai de ceux qui étaient déjà là sous
la ivème
qui s'occupe survécu quand même mais
phénomène de nouveauté des nouveaux
candidats qui surgissent allez on change
on chante on oublie le passé les
français suivent l'homme du référendum
toutes les grandes figures de la
quatrième république sont battus
d'edouard daladier à pierre mendès
france en passant par françois
mitterrand ou bien encore le communiste
jacques duclos le général de gaulle a
gagné son pari la nouvelle république
est sur les rails avec une majorité
gouvernementale
et nouveauté ces élections législatives
vont permettre la mise en place d'un
parlementarisme rationnalisé une
expression qui date de l'après première
guerre mondiale dont qui consiste à dire
le parlement est là le parlement a deux
fonctions fondamentales voter la loi
contre le gouvernement ça il ya un
accord total là dessus depuis toujours
mais en même temps il faut que les
règles relatives au fonctionnement du
parlement les règles relatives aux
relations entre le parlement et le
gouvernement soit organisée de telle
manière qu'il y ait la plus grande
stabilité possible pour le gouvernement
et quand tout a le parlement soit dans
une situation où il ne bloque pas le
travail du gouvernement taxé d un
parlement où on discute - on délibère -
on passe moins de temps à des
controverses houleuses
l'exécutif et y devient gouvernante
autonome a plus de poids
l'exécutif prend désormais ses marques
les nouvelles institutions ne remettent
pas en cause le mode d'élection du
président de la république ni la durée
du mandat présidentiel
par rapport aux institutions de la
troisième de la quatrième république
dans lesquelles seuls les parlementaires
élisait le chef de l'état le collège
électoral présidentiel et hilario
conseillers généraux aux membres des
assemblées les territoires d'outre-mer
et aux représentants d'élus des conseils
municipaux
le général de gaulle est élu par un
collège d'environ 80 mille personnes qui
sont pour l'essentiel des délégués des
conseils municipaux face aux candidats
en lice l'élection se résume à une
formalité le 21 décembre 1958 charles de
gaulle est élu président avec soissons
18,5 pour cent des suffrages face au
communiste georges marrane et aux
mathématiciens albert châtelet qui ont
fait de la figuration
ça lui donne une assise un peu plus
importante que ne l'était celle des
présidents de la troisième ou la
quatrième république le 8 janvier 1959
charles de gaulle est investi président
de la république
il est alors saluons ces termes par rené
coty milliers de français
[Musique]
mirambeau mais nouveau président de la
république nomme michel debré premier
ministre et le général va peser sa
signature très rapidement il va avec
rené coty à l'ordre de triomphe pour
ranimer la flamme du soldat inconnu
ensuite il repart l'elysée seules en
abandonnant rené coty son
s'occuper de lui le moins du monde au
fond ils n'acceptent pas d'être le
successeur de rené coty qui ne tient pas
personnellement l'an grande estime il
est le premier président d'une vème
république qui vient de naître et donc
comme il le dira dans
ses mémoires d'espoir me voici désormais
à l'elysée les institutions sont
acceptés de l'elysée comment vais-je les
modeler l'homme du 18-juin aime les
symboles il s'agit de marquer de son
empreinte la constitution et les
premières lignes les pouvoirs du
président de la république sont définies
dans le titre 2 de la constitution alors
qu'il n'apparaissait qu'en cinquième
position dans la précédente le présent
la république à la première place des
institutions ce qui montre aussi
immédiatement la volonté du constituant
un lecteur de la constitution d'accorder
une place particulière au chef de l'état
la priorité présent a pu quitter le
gouvernement si la priorité de
l'exécutif
donc de la stabilité donc de
l'efficacité de l'action gouvernementale
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs michel debré
utilisera l'image
architectural du président de la
république clé de voûte cette fois ci la
force parlementaire et la force
gouvernementale et ce qui tient ses
présidents dans l'esprit du général et
dans sa pratique c'est le chef de l'état
qui est le véritable chef du
gouvernement la primauté du président de
la république ressort à plusieurs
reprises dans la constitution notamment
dans l'article 5 ce qu'il faut retenir
le article 5 c'est que c'est le gardien
ou le garant politique que la
constitution des institutions du bon
fonctionnement des institutions de
l'intégrité du territoire des traités
c'est à dire que c'est véritablement une
disposition qui donne est légitime
quelque part lusage par le président de
la république de compétences
extraordinaires mais des compétences
réelles par exemple le droit dissolution
par exemple l'appel au peuple avec le
référendum par exemple la domination
premier ministre la constitution de 1958
a donc posé les premières briques de la
vème république
mais le général de gaulle voit plus loin
il a déjà un coude avance il élabore
dans le secret des mini star il a dit
les hommes politiques en face de moi
jouent à la belote mais moi je joue au
poker
sa première carte ils la jouent en 1960
face à des députés hostiles à son projet
de dissuasion nucléaire ils demandent au
premier ministre michel debré d'utiliser
pour la première fois la procédure de
l'article 49-3 alors l'article 49 alinéa
3 de la constitution mais les
parlementaires dans l'obligation soit
d'accepter le texte du gouvernement soit
de censurer le texte du gouvernement
plus exactement de quoi il s'agit face à
l'absence d'une majorité sur un tel don
controversé mais considéré comme étant
décisif essentiel par le pouvoir
exécutif le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité sur le texte qui oblige
l'opposition de déposer une motion de
censure s'il n'y a pas de dépôt de
motion de censure le texte est considéré
comme adopté un an plus tard dans la
nuit du 21 avril 1961 et généraux
françaises et leurs châles joué salle en
prennent le contrôle d'al j pour mettre
un terme à la crise de gaulle s'adresse
aux français le 23 avril à la télévision
il s'attribue en direct les pleins
pouvoirs comme prévu par l'article 16 de
la constitution l'article 16 c'est le
prolongement de l'article 5 c'est à dire
que lorsque l'article 5 est en cause
lorsque l'intégrité du territoire est en
cause lorsque le glas conduit les
pouvoirs publics est en cause et sont
menacés et c'est bon on peut utiliser
ces pouvoirs exceptionnels on retrouve
là aussi du style de gaulle c'est un
article qui donne quand même les pleins
pouvoirs un homme dans des situations de
crise et quand je dis les pleins
pouvoirs c'est vraiment les plans
pouvoir pouvoir exécutif pouvoirs
législatif et judiciaire tout l'art mais
les pouvoirs civils et préfet la police
et c'est ce qu'on appelle un pouvoir
d'exception l'article 16
son origine ce sont les souvenirs de
1940 il faut toujours se souvenir que
ceux qui écrivent la constitution de 58
avait 20 ans de moins en 1938 c'est à
dire au moment de la crise de munich et
du déclenchement de la guerre et c'est
très très présent dans le dans leur
esprit et dans leur réaction c'est
l'idée que lorsque la france est en
péril il faut que le président de la
république puisse l'incarner
complètement l'article 16 est une
réponse à l'histoire parce qu'on ne sait
pas ce qui peut se passer dans notre
pays on ne sait pas dire qu'un pays
c'est pas une eau dormante
après la signature des accords d'evian
du 18 mars 1962 qui met fin à huit ans
de guerre entre l'algérie et la france
le général de gaulle va montrer une
nouvelle fois qu'il est le maître du jeu
en désaccord avec michel debré sur la
question algérienne il décide alors de
l'écarter le président de la république
demande au premier ministre michel debré
de démissionner alors que l'assemblée
nationale vient de lui voter la
confiance à une forte majorité
donc ils montrent que ils négligent le
vote de l'assemblée nationale s'il
appartient bien au président de la
république et à lui seul de nommer le
premier ministre il n'a pas le pouvoir
de le destituer seule l'assemblée
nationale peut renverser le gouvernement
par des procédures bien défini soit en
lui refusant la confiance lorsqu'il
engage sa responsabilité sont en votant
une motion de censure entraînant sa
chute c'est à dire que pour faire tomber
un gouvernement il ne faut pas assembler
les gens qui en compte il faut que les
gens qui sont content puisse avoir la
solution de remplacement ce sont les
mécanismes qui régissent les articles 49
et 50 de la constitution mais le général
de gaulle l'a passé outre un port au
général de gaulle qui expliquait en 58
devant le comité consultatif
constitutionnel que jamais un président
n'a appli pouvait virer un premier
ministre parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'on est dans un autre type de régime
là il le fait tranquillement et nomma
premier sans même demander l'avis du du
du parlement on a compris en 62 c'était
sa cinquième appelé voilà
il va nommer pour remplacer michel debré
georges pompidou que personne sauf le
petit cénacle des initiés ne connais qui
n'est pas parlementaire qui n'est pas un
homme politique
qui a comme principal le garantis pour
le général de gaulle d'avoir été son
directeur de cabinet ça présente une
autre vertu pour le président de la
république est un chef de gouvernement
c'est que il n'y a pas de pression
particulière de chantage particulier du
ministre vis-à-vis du chef du
gouvernement et vis-à-vis du président
de la république le général de gaulle
voulait que les mini soit indépendant
des parlementaires ne soit pas sous
influence des parlementaires est soi
même détachée du parlement c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs au général de gaulle
a recruté de très nombreux ministres
pendant l'exercice de ce pouvoir en
dehors du parlement renforcé le pouvoir
de l'exécutif le solidifier si tout seul
en mission du général de gaulle à ce
moment là que le général de gaulle de 10
il faut qu'on passe à l'élection au
suffrage universel direct c'est la seule
façon d'assurer la pérennité de la
primauté présidentielle mais un autre
événement va renforcer sa conviction le
22 août 1962 le général échappe
miraculeusement à un attentat au
petit-clamart organisées par les
partisans de l'algérie française
une question désormais se pose et si de
gaulle venait à disparaître
que se passerait-il c'est l'attentât du
petit clamart qui fait dire au général
de gaulle attention j'aurai un
successeur il faut préparer la
légitimité de ce successeur pour moi pas
de problème
j'avais cette légitimité ce prestige de
héros du 18 juin 1940 mais ceux qui vont
me suivre auront besoin d'une légitimité
du suffrage universel pour s'imposer aux
assemblées il est persuadé qu'il faut
aller vite car il est mortel d'autant
plus que certains veulent saveur
politique et d'autres sa mort physique
et c'est comme ça que on va rentrer dans
le référendum de 1962 sur l'élection du
président abu cosy phrase universel pour
réviser la constitution dans le texte de
1958 il y à une disposition particulière
c'est l'article 89 la marge de manoeuvre
est étroite alors comment imposer cette
révision à une classe politique qui n'en
veut pas cette disposition particulière
permet au président de la république
d'engager un processus de révision à
deux conditions la première c'est qu'il
ya un accord en termes identiques entre
les députés et les sénateurs et la
deuxième il faut que ce texte soit
ratifié soit par trois cinquièmes des
parlementaires réunis à versailles en
congrès soit par référendum
du coup il est certain que le texte ne
sera pas voté dans des termes identiques
par les deux chambres part du conseil
des ministres du 12 septembre 1962 il
propose de recourir à l'article 11 en
vertu duquel le président de la
république peut soumettre au référendum
tout projet de loi portant sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics
20 septembre il présente son projet aux
français
mais comme toujours
je ne peux et ne veux rien accomplir
qu'avec votre cocon comme toujours
je vais donc bientôt vous le demandez
alors comme toujours c'est vous qui en
déciderez la quasi-totalité des juristes
et tout style et la méthode employée par
le général de gaulle les juristes qui
réagissent plutôt sur les modalités de
la révision de la constitution puisque
le jeu vers de gaulle va utiliser
l'article 11 de la constitution qui est
un article prévu pour faire un effort
législatif
et il va pas utiliser l'article 89 de la
constitution qui est l'article prévu
pour réviser la constitution donc ils
disent les juristes disent en substance
cela il ya violation des règles
constitutionnelles
le conseil d'état émet alors un avis
défavorable à l'utilisation de l'article
11 le conseil constitutionnel se déclare
incompétent quant à la classe politique
elle est vent debout contre le projet de
révision cette annonce va faire
l'unanimité pratiquement contre le
général de gaulle à la seule exception
de son propre parti du parti gaulliste
de l'umr le parti communiste
se déclare évidemment contre
cette idée les autres partis politiques
des socialistes aux indépendants en
passant par les radicaux les mrp cetera
vont constituer un cartel des noms pour
demander aux français de voter non à
cette réforme constitutionnelle
à la tête du cartel des noms on trouve
notamment le président du sénat gaston
monnerville au congrès du parti radical
le 29 septembre ce dernier qualifie de
forfaiture la méthode employée par de
gaulle mais celui ci est inflexible et
c'est ce qui conduit l'assemblée
nationale a voté le 5 octobre une motion
de censure contre le gouvernement
pompidou le cartel des noms c'est un
collier deux hommes politiques la
plupart de la 4e et ces gens là sont pas
rendu compte que dans l'esprit du public
c'était le passé contre l'avenir parce
qu'ils avaient été pré cités connu
utilisé bien avant sous la quatrième
république ils avaient tous été dix fois
quinze fois vingt fois ministre sous la
ivème il arrive elle a usé pour eux le
régime politique de la france ne peut
être qu'un régime dans lequel la clé de
voûte des institutions cepal présent la
brique c'est le parlement à la tribune
l'assemblée nationale
j'ai senti physiquement
que le mauvais génie d'autrefois étaient
de nouveau présents dans l'hémicycle
j'ai vu la grande majorité de
l'assemblée nationale depuis les
communistes inclus jusqu'au sympathisent
bloess également inclus je les ai vues
animées
- par le désir d'exercer un droit de
contrôle légitime de la politique du
gouvernement
que par la passion de renverser tout ce
qui s'oppose au règne exclusif des
partis qui est-ce qui visait c'est pas
c'est pas con qui nous celui qui visait
se présente la république et c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui amène la crise c'est à
dire que c'est le seul gouvernement de
renverser de la vème république mais
c'est aussi immédiatement derrière une
des solutions c'est que les
parlementaires croit encore qu'il est
possible d'atteindre le président la
pluie qui à travers son premier ministre
le général réplique aussitôt alors que
le gouvernement pompidou a été mise en
minorité il le reconduit dans ses
fonctions et prononce la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
de nouvelles élections législatives sont
prévues pour les 18 et 25 novembre
1962 mais avant cela du gold 20
consulter les français par référendum la
campagne du référendum nous sommes deux
se fait sur le suffrage universel
n'oubliez pas la majorité c'est vous
thème qui sera repris en 67 la majorité
c'est vous c'est à dire chaque français
se sent concerné en la décision du chef
de l'état mme état d'esprit des français
c'est
une immense reconnaissance au général de
gaulle d'avoir arrêté la guerre
d'algérie et puis également une
reconnaissance du fait que depuis son
arrivée au pouvoir la france à 1
vision internationale qu'elle n'avait
pas auparavant que le général de gaulle
est une voix qu'on écoute que l'économie
française se porte bien que le contrôle
de l'état sur l'économie
permet une augmentation permanente des
revenus donc il y a à la fois des
opposants incontestablement au nom des
principes politiques et en même temps
une satisfaction des français sur les
résultats de l'action du président de la
république et c'est sur cette balance là
que va se dérouler le référendum
d'octobre
1962 le oui l emporte alors avec un peu
plus de 60% des suffrages
on n'a pas une majorité aussi éclatante
qu'en 1958 pour les institutions de la
vème république
mais c'est quand même une majorité
confortable
60% des suffrages exprimés en faveur
donc de cette révision
constitutionnelle est donc ça donne un
surcroît de légitimité
un surcroît de prestige au général de
gaulle
les partis traditionnels sont battus ils
le seront de nouveau aux élections
législatives des 18 et 25 novembre
lui est né argot liste et leurs alliés
les républicains indépendants obtienne
la majorité absolue des sièges
l'assemblée nationale
c'est une nouvelle victoire du général
de gaulle c'est quand même la première
fois qu'on a une vraie majorité à
l'assemblée nationale les élections du
18 et du 25 novembre donne une majorité
qui va stable cohérente et homogène
c'est un grand grand événement dans la
vie politique française c'est là qu'on
rend dingue nouveau monde avant ces des
tâtonnements avancé dé des histoires de
conjoncture avant on est encore pendant
la guerre d'algérie donc beaucoup de
choses s'expliquent par la peur des
conséquences de la guerre d'algérie à
partir de 62 on est vraiment sous la
vème république c'est ce que raymond
aron a appelé je crois à juste titre la
deuxième naissance de la vème république
si vous la constitution est né en 1958
la vème république en tant que régime
politique avec le poids de son président
et son système majoritaire même y
compris ces périodes de cohabitation est
né à l'automne 1962 à la fin de l'année
62 de gaulle à a réalisé le grand chelem
il a à ses institutions de la vème
république il à la présidence de la
république qui désormais sera
concrétisé enraciné couronné par le
suffrage universel et puis il a une
majorité parlementaire totalement à ses
ordres il va pouvoir véritablement
mettre en oeuvre toutes ces réformes et
je dirais exercer la constitution de la
vème république
dans toute sa plénitude la constitution
de 1958 porte indéniablement l'empreinte
du général de gaulle si elle n'a pas
encore battu le record en durée de la
troisième république
elle a permis à la france d'être
gouvernée démocratiquement bien au delà
de la disparition du général il reste
une constitution qui s'adapte aux
contextes nationaux internationaux
économiques politiques sociaux qui
résiste à tous les alternances les
cohabitations il faut bien constater que
la constitution d'un cinquième
république est un une sorte de véhicule
tout terrain parce qu'elle s'adapte à
toutes les situations politiques depuis
60 ans la grande force de cette
constitution de la vème république
c'est d'avoir été suffisamment ambigu
dans sa formulation pour lui permettre
de s'adapter à plusieurs époques la vème
république
c'est à la fois le temps pour gouverner
légitimité qui permet la continuité de
l'action en même temps le contrôle
populaire
[Musique]